[Musique]
j'étais à l'unité des adolescents en
psychiatrie pendant environ un mois
je suis un rendez vous médicaux souvent
ici c'était de temps car elle qui m'a
proposé le projet au début je garde
aussi de lancer courra dans quoi je
m'embarquais
en douze semaines apprendre à jouer du
violoncelle monter un spectacle ou
s'initier aux beaux-arts au musée du
même nom c'est la transition que
l'hôpital sainte-justine offre aux
jeunes patients de psychiatrie une fois
leur état stabilisé
ce n'est pas un projet d'art thérapie
c'est un projet pour amener le jeune a
retrouvé ses points de repère dans la
vie normalement ça ne se passe pas
l'hôpital ça se passe avec des artistes
ce sont des vrais artistes qui voit les
jeunes comme des jeunes pas comme des
patients
dans les cours de violoncelle que
j'avais ici à l'espace concession j'ai
pu vraiment communiquer avec les autres
personnes qui pète avait un lien comme
hugo man avec moi ils ont été un hôpital
il doit recommencer mais on est vraiment
une famille on fait tellement de choses
que j'ai pu le temps de penser ma vie
espace transition qui a commencé il ya
dix ans avec des ateliers donnés par le
cirque du soleil s'est grandement
diversifiée
c'est les remettre dans la vie c'est de
les mobiliser c'est de leur faire
prendre conscience de leur potentiel
c'est de le sortir de ce carcan des
malades pour qu'ils reprennent le
contrôle sur leur vie et sens le fait
donc au plus l'art est extraordinaire
pour ça que ce soit le théâtre le cirque
la musique bientôt l'opéra le musée des
beaux-arts plus le fait de prendre ma
place parce que je suis quelqu'un de
naturellement introverti de nature
anxieuse et introverti puis ensuite
aller sur scène ça me permet le juste
sortir tout ce qui bouge à l'intérieur
de moitié juste un autre endroit où on
peut se laisser aller sans se faire
juger puis où on rencontre de nouveaux
amis justement et c'est ça crée un lien
puissant
moi je vis beaucoup de stress beaucoup
beaucoup de presse alors c'est bien
d'avoir un endroit où je peux vraiment
me relaxer et tout oublié ils sont nous
permettent pas d'autre chemin dans la
vie merci à vous tous d'avoir d'avoir
accepté d'être là d'être filmé vous êtes
une des roues on va dire que le choix du
violoncelle n'est pas au hasard chez
monde
du climat et des mois dans dans ma vie
personnelle un instrument qu'on en lasse
et dont il faut prendre grand soin ici
and with despatie radio-canada à
montréal
[Musique]